Rusia se echó para atrás su decisión de
no continuar con la implementación del
acuerdo para la exportación de cereales
que permiten medio de la guerra en
Ucrania un corredor para la salida de
estos alimentos a través del mar Negro
no duró ni una semana
he dado instrucciones al Ministerio de
defensa para que se reanuda nuestra
participación en ese trabajo sin embargo
Rusia Se reserva el derecho de retirarse
de estos acuerdos y Ucrania viola las
garantías
exigimos seguridades y garantías de la
parte ucraniana
Moscú Había decidido retirarse del pacto
el 29 de octubre tras acusar a kiev de
atacar con drones a una flota rusa en
aguas de sebastopol en la anexionada
Península de crimea y a pesar de que
Ucrania y Naciones Unidas continuaron el
acuerdo sin Rusia su retiro preocupó a
la comunidad internacional por la
seguridad de las embarcaciones antes de
la invasión Ucrania solía suministrar 45
millones de toneladas de cereales al
mercado global cada año convirtiéndose
en uno de los mayores exportadores de
verano en el mundo el acuerdo logrado el
22 de Julio entre Rusia y Ucrania con
mediación de Turquía y Naciones Unidas
busca abastecer de alimentos a países y
regiones en riesgo de hambruna como
yemen y el cuerno de África
según Naciones Unidas el acuerdo ha
permitido hasta el momento transportar
casi 10 millones de toneladas de
cereales aceite y soya en barcos que
zarpan de Puerto ucranianos comodesa y
atracan en Estambul donde se encuentra
el centro de coordinación conjunta que
se encarga inspeccionar las
embarcaciones
el ministro de defensa de Rusia señor
yoigo llamó a nuestro ministro de
defensa o luciacar y expresó que el
transporte de granos continuará como se
tenía acordado anteriormente
el acuerdo finalizará el 19 de noviembre